and I think part of it is before it was
a religious kind of irrational type
investment right very very similar like
a venture capital investment so it's
either gonna be worth you know boatloads
more than it is now or is gonna be worth
zero and say a lot of people looked at
it that way
now what people say is well hold on a
second forget what asset it is I know
what's happening on the economic side
cuz we're talking about on television
every day right and the numbers are just
mind-boggling what can I do right and
there's really only three things you
could do I guess four things you could
do right in the short term you can hold
dollars you can old gold you can ol
antique an old Bitcoin right and maybe
there's some other you know kind of
crazy exotic things whatever but for the
most part those are four easy to
understand examples in the medium term
you probably can still hold dollars you
can owe gold land and Bitcoin in the
long term you can't really hold dollars
Yeah right because it's gonna end up
getting devalued away so now you're back
to gold real estate Bitcoin and yes I'm
sure that there will be the inflation of
stock prices along the way but you still
have that dislocation between the actual
economic underlying data and an asset
price and so you know Paul Tudor Jones
wrote it I thought really well where he
said look the fastest horse wins right
and it's I think all of these are gonna
go up but this one specifically and it
reminded me I I gotta go back and get it
I wrote um this is in March I wrote a
piece ranking all of the assets over the
next two years and I gave stocks like an
eight out of ten right I gave oil like
uh I think was like a five out of ten
and I said gold is gonna go over two
thousand I think is gonna end up from
between two thousand twenty-five hundred
bucks but it's a two out of ten because
that's really not that big of a move
compared to something like a Bitcoin
where the vault oh he's gonna work in
its favor right you're gonna get this
massive increase in in price and what
shocked me was how many like traditional
Wall Street folks reached out and they
said wait a minute you're telling me
that the same drivers of you know gold
or real estate is going to be the driver
of Bick
that to me more yeah you're already
convinced that those other two S's we're
gonna do well because of all the
monetary stimulus stuff right and so I
think that's where you're gonna see the
kind of confidence built is that
connection between what drives this
price compared to that macro environment
but another way to back into high
conviction around a Bitcoin along is
going back to the incentive structure
for the Fed to put the S&P 500 at 5,000
again the way I was framing willing able
incentivize with a track record of
printing look at that pension liability
problem we need this thing at 5,000 and
you think about that as the backdrop
there's no way Bitcoin doesn't work if
that call is correct
there's a you it's highly unlikely that
Bitcoin doesn't work in a really really
big way and obviously from percent
return perspective works massively but
you know that's a double so that's a
double in the S&P 500 from here alright
a little a little less than a double
well if that's the backdrop then I mean
BTC is gonna be fifty thousand plus it
is but it is and maybe there's a chance
that Satoshi moves his coins maybe
there's a chance that somebody does some
of the blockchain somebody steals all a
clone bit in some catastrophic
idiosyncratic type of risk and you got
to manage around those and that's why
there's active management but like
that backdrop it's really really
unlikely that Bitcoin doesn't work in a
big way there yeah yeah and I think we
were talking about is structurally
Bitcoin couldn't be better set up for
what we're seeing right and and it's
just interest rates drop you get
printing of money you've got a store
value asset that is based on an
artificially cap supply and you just had
the having right like that's the part
that that's so crazy to me is a lot of
the analysis I see right now talks about
Bitcoin in the macro environment and
they basically like this protector
having isn't even here right it's like
that same part of the analysis when you
add in that part I continue to tell
people it's like gold in 2009 when
everyone should have been buying gold
before it went up almost 200% imagine it
50% of the gold miners just shut off
mm-hm right and they just say hey look
have to half the gold supply that you
thought was coming on mine's not coming
online now yeah it's been pretty severe
on Bitcoin that's been incredible to
watch over the last couple months it is
people talk about antifragility a lot
throw that around a lot but the
juxtaposition of bitcoins antifragility
relative to how obviously fragile
traditional financial markets have
become and so so incredibly distorted
and specifically you think about Black
Thursday and that peak to trough Bitcoin
is down 50 percent in 24 hours really
hate to see that for your if you're
gunning for the world reserve currency
being down 15 24 hours the big problem
right I get that
but the bounce the magnitude of the
bounce and how spot driven it's been and
also specifically around antifragility
this is this is a set up around Black
Thursday is leveraged driven people
gotten real build up on the having
people were super super long on on the
potential swaps across all the platforms
tethered borrow rates or super high
contango was blown out I did a little
podcast with Nathaniel Whitmore with it
On February 14th at the end of it he
asked me what do you the biggest risk is
right now and what are you most worried
about
I said how levered this market is right
now it's very levered long as a month
before and
that was an untenable situation and last
time
Bitcoin encountered a big untenable
situation was the BCH BSB Fork
a hash rate war thing in November 2018
and Bitcoin did it down 50 then - took a
couple weeks but it did it down 50 what
happened after that was bit main and
Geon woo and Craig ride and Calvin air
and all the clown shows their role in
this ecosystem was diminished to the
point that it got a lot lot harder for
them to do something bad Bitcoin and
don't you run down 50 right but it
bounced all the way back in this on the
other leverage situation very untenable
you roll through to Black Thursday down
50 in 24 hours but you shook it that was
a nuclear bomb event in terms of the
market structure for Bitcoin I can just
tell you that without getting into
detail it was just like and the entire
market structure changed and that entire
buying back I mean the vast majority of
the bounce f after Black Thursday was
very much a spot driven it was just not
derivatives led it was not leverage led
and it was mostly us spot and US retail
and the herd and we know a little bit
more about what the herd did now with a
little bit of hindsight right herds been
buying again Paul Tudor Jones don't have
any friends
and and you get to where we are today
and you now have us it wherever we're at
right now
9k and but there's the foundation
underneath where we are at the price
level is much much more sound and don't
get me wrong Asia is you know still the
800-pound gorilla in the room but the
balance
from from a bunch of different angles
looks to us to have been us-led and
that's real healthy and I think it's
directly in response to both retail
investors high-net-worth a guy buying
$200 on coinbase every from him to Paul
Tudor Jones everybody's looking at
what's going on monetary and fiscal
policies and they're going probably were
taking a little flyer on this this may
be the best heads on the face of the
planet for this thing and the market
caps the size of Costco so I should you
know might be worth doing